what's that like going into a fight for
you like the leading up to the fight are
you are have you already thought about
your game plan you're just trying to
keep busy until you get in the ring or
are you like
what are you thinking about as you're
walking into the ring
um
i get into a very like meta deep
meditative state so i get there we get
there an hour before and i'm constantly
just nasal breathing a lot like playing
with different breath holds like long
inhales long exhales long exhale holds
and just for like that whole hour i'm
very conscious of my breath and i feel
like i get into a
like a meditative state to where i'm
calm
but i'm ready to kill like it's like in
kills like this guy's trying to kill me
i'm trying to kill him you know i think
if you ever see any backstage footage of
me
i'm sitting there
very calm like
just meditating um and then when i hit
mids i'm conscious of my my breath the
whole time um so walking out i'm just
you know feeling my breath and it just
it helps me get into
get into my breath and out of my head
i'm not overthinking anything i'm not
nervous i'm not you're not nervous no i
i haven't been nervous for a fight in a
long time it i'm nervous watching it
my hands are sweaty just hearing you
dude i get nervous watching like people
that i care about fight um
my girl and i can't
we almost can't take it
when doug rose fights i know well she
like makes you [ __ ] nervous because
she looks like she's about to have a
melt now and i'm like oh god i don't
know if she should be in there but she's
the best in the [ __ ] world like she
dared she's just
she's so rad dude it's trippy watching
her walk out because it's like it's just
super emotional it's like she's like
wearing her emotions on the outside
right which is
everyone does their own thing and it
makes it works for her she's a [ __ ]
beast and then where's your head at like
in the fight like are you
thinking about
doing it or is it like instinct and like
something happens you're like oh that
was cool that i just did like i didn't
even plan i can't even answer that
because i feel like i'm not in the cage
i just completely let go and have like a
higher i just trust that the last six
weeks seven eight weeks whatever it was
that the work was put in and i
completely just like autopilot almost
flow state
i just whatever happens happens and i
just completely let go of
all thought and i mean that's the goal
and i feel like i've been pretty good at
that and i think my performances show
that um but yeah if you're thinking in
there you're you're a step behind you
got to be flowing and just
it's a it's a
second i'd be like tom cruises in the
audience [ __ ] dude cindy crawford oh my
god you know like that happens like
there's split seconds where there's
things like that happen
like like like tom like some of you will
catch your eye or no not even i feel
like that last fight i was just so
[ __ ] locked in and dialed in and
thankfully i was because that kid
[ __ ] brought it like i needed every
ounce of energy that i used in there to
whoop that dude's ass and it worked but
i remember i'm trying to think back like
i i do remember like seeing someone one
time in a fight and thinking like oh
well and then like snap back into it
but after was it i don't remember but i
do after my last fight i went back and
rewatched it
and uh and i saw trump already in the
audience when you were fighting i didn't
see trump but i've seen bieber and
bieber in the in the video
the last like 45 seconds the crowd went
crazy and i'm dotting this dude up
bieber and his dad stand up and like i
thought that was the coolest [ __ ]
thing ever that one of the best
performers in the world justin bieber
was like standing up in awe of what i
was doing and i was like oh that was
sick like that was cool that was cool he
brought him to his feet brought him to
his feet and like the whole arena was
standing up it was that was pretty crazy
i mean it's weird you're you're a savage
gladiator like
i mean people are watching you
entertain them by [ __ ] somebody up
yeah and they're like
yeah it's weird fighting such a weird
[ __ ] sport it's like looking at it
now that i'm in camp like if you if we
were doing this podcast two weeks after
my fight
like i feel like i'd be i'm a different
person like a lot of food private way
different conversations obviously we're
talking about the fight now but
like the last six weeks i've been in
camp which is like no drinking sleeping
good eating clean training hard like
just like i'm a different person inside
of camp and outside of camp yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]